oh one second hello yeah let me call you
back I'm gonna interview with GQ
what's up GQ this is Denzel curry and
these are my essentials
[Music]
first essential thing that our months
presents is this nutribullet now see
most people don't know I like blending I
like mixing up drinks I like making my
own smoothies a moment juices and stuff
like that you know my father showed me
how to use a blender he was like amen
I'm gonna make you a smoothie but I'm
guarantee you this is gonna knock you
out and I was like no it's not so you
know I tasted it not knowing there was
alcohol inside it next thing you know
I'm watching Billy and Mandy and boom
knocked out cold sleep this book is
called one punch man
I read while I'm on tour and I read this
book a lot because it is funny the main
character was supposed to be unbeatable
right and he's obviously unbeatable
which makes it funny so the real focus
is on the characters around one punch
man and not exactly one punch man but it
still goes back to one punch man let's
go with these shoes got these running
shoes right here you got a workout shoes
and then you got shoes that you know
when you go out you're supposed to look
good right so these are specifically
meant for like running shoes and I use
these shoes to workout jump rope play
basketball play football but majority
just a run trying to get you know the
Chi up to exercise I would like to get
in this PlayStation 4 ok be careful ok
there you go
ps4 a lot of memories I had a ps1 back
when I was a kid and now the ps4 yeah I
got games too this junk force which is
basically like majority of all the anime
characters and this one game fighting
each other most people didn't like this
game but I like this game because I get
to play it with my friends and fam
that's one we have got a war for if you
know about God award you know about
Kratos you know about him going against
the Greek gods Ares Zeus here this is
Norse mythology so you're gonna get stor
you're gonna get a boulder you're gonna
guess all these people that you see
pretty much in like that
Odin universe and get
or Norse mythology resident evil cream
about resident was not to be creepy like
zombies that could exists you know if a
zombie apocalypse happened right now
where would you know wrong there's no
food
better get a gun already and go to the
nearest food store and try to take over
all the food stores that's what I'll do
Soul Calibur if you ever play Tekken
this should be easy
this should be second nature to you but
this deals you like swords swords me and
my brother used to want the heads
because of this game this motor combat
and star wars revenged itself I would
have had Grand Theft Auto here but I
left it at the house and I would have
had Mortal Kombat 11 here but I left the
house I do not play online because I'm
afraid of getting my ass whupped by you
six year olds out there that just stay
in the house and beat Grauman's ass so
here we go now this is my North Face
jacket I have two of them there is a
yellow one that I always wear and I was
wearing it when I was on a tablet or it
kept me warm get me cozy the thing about
this jacket is has like a lot of cool
components to it like I have a backpack
inside this jacket and whoever made this
is a [ __ ] genius
excuse my french and the design when it
is amazing because it looks like a
backpack but it's also a jacket and it
has 3m we've shot some light on it and
gleamed especially if you take a photo
at night it really pops I'm not really a
fashion guy but I love looking at cool
stuff
whoa this is a pouch from palace I put
my stuff in here you want to see what I
have in here and my wallet have
something to clean my goals and I also
have
another set of gold's sometimes I feel
like regular teeth sometimes I feel like
just regular golds and sometimes I feel
like banks the reason why I keep golds
with me because it's a significant thing
cuz being raised in Miami Florida Dade
County Broward County West Palm Beach
we all wear gold a lot of us got dreads
someone's to cut our dreads off some of
us you know take our goals out and most
of us get permanent I won't get
permanent make your best thing that's
why I keep a whole bunch of gold's with
me
oh no everybody know how much I play you
know and it's a good pastime for anybody
I'm just saying straight up out of my
mouth y'all have some dumbass rules like
come on you could put a draw for a draw
to you just gonna expect me to draw two
and not use the draw two on somebody
else and if they got another draw is
gonna hit somebody else that makes the
game more funner not saying that you
guys did a bad job just saying some of
the rules could be a little better
always keep a deck of cards with you
because you never know when you're about
to be bored right here all my art looks
just did a self-portrait and I drew a
receptionist if you think that's too
childish and kiddush I have a taste for
sci-fi science fiction also designed a
bike as an artist I like Todd McFarlane
one the God who created one punch man o
mob cycle akira toriyama who did it
Dragonball Z H R Giger who also did
species and alien laptop always
essential because this is where I do
business this is where I listen to music
because I'll be typing on here we were
creating stories sometimes I gotta email
people sometimes I got some tracks back
down low but also I go on YouTube
YouTube is like my main goal ting right
I love
YouTube I don't really subscribe anymore
you know back when I was a teenager I
used to watch this show called
epicMealTime used to make me so hungry
and damn one day we was like you know I
want to make a long breakfast cake it
was like you would do something weird
like that and then the main person who
was like you would do something like
that and they were eating the cake so
like okay that's how I learned how to
like kind of cook you know besides my
mother and my brothers like I said with
the workout shoes yeah I work out on
tour right pop this bad boy up on any
door and you just get to live in your
own bodyweight I ended up getting mad
upper body strength moves just using
this pull-up bar and everything you just
non-stop gonna stop every Hotel non-stop
non-stop calisthenics I would recommend
counter snakes if you not into lifting
heavy weights just lift your own
bodyweight that's hard enough as it is
you know just lifting yourself up that's
hard
well not for me you have a martial
speaker now when you workout whatever
you doing when you cleaned up your bus
clean up your house or you just want to
listen to music this bad boy is gonna do
the trick for you
everybody's music everybody loves music
even babies love music like lullabies
and stuff like that it doesn't matter
what brand it is JBL I like JBL but also
like Marshall it doesn't matter they get
the job done I listen to music clothes I
don't want them to be like oh he's Pro
more shoe on
we can't sponsor him even skull candy
shop skull candy
crockpot I'm gonna be totally honest yes
I bought a crock pot but I don't know
how to use it yet but since we're going
on tour and we're gonna be on a big-ass
place you need one of these things
because you don't know when you're gonna
get trapped in a city that you don't
want to be in get groceries get some
rice cuz I'm shaking get some fish and
you cook it in this bad boy right here
and then that way you don't have to pay
for food you're cooking the food
yourself and the only thing you're
paying for is the groceries and
everybody doing a bus to satisfy we can
eat like a family who brings a lot of
people together because everybody's
hungry well that was it this is Denso
curry signing off
which
and these are my essentials
[Music]